I have a very vivid memory of
my GP
saying to me
you are mentally sick and you have to
accept help to get better
Hannah was a healthy 20 year old
psychology student living at home with
her family when she started experiencing
flu-like symptoms
[Music]
I went to my GP and I was kind of told
viruses will just generally go you just
need to go home and rest take it easy
her GP thought she had glandular fever
Hannah was feeling very tired so the
symptoms fitted but then she started to
develop changes in her personality soon
after Hannah lost her ability to speak I
had to ask my mom to come in say it
would be and talk for me to the GP I
would kind of write down to my man what
needed to be said Hannah was sent home
with antidepressants and a referral to a
psychologist
her symptoms deteriorated and she was
soon admitted to a psychiatric hospital
where she was given antipsychotic
medication
she was seen by a psychiatrist who
ordered an MRI scan during the scan
doctors found a cyst on her brain and
sent her to a e for investigation when I
got to a e they reviewed the cyst and
said I was probably born with it
probably had nothing to do with the
symptoms
but what they did notice was that my
blood test showed I was fighting some
sort of virus more tests followed and
after three weeks the results came back
and Hannah finally got her diagnosis
anti-nmda receptor Encephalitis if a
autoimmune form of encephalitis which is
the inflammation of the brain
according to Professor guy lash sinner
having your physical symptoms mistaken
for a mental illness is not uncommon we
do occasionally see individuals with
very severe psychosis and behavioral
change in whom the initial diagnosis is
of a psychotic illness like
schizophrenia
but actually over the course of days or
weeks whilst they're in hospital it
begins to be obvious that actually what
is underlying their condition is one of
these autoimmune conditions it's been
known for more than a century that
damaged to particular parts of the brain
and things like tumors can result in
changes in personality or behavior but
over the last 20 years or so we've begun
to recognize that there are a number of
conditions that have an immune basis
whereby the immune system attacks the
brain and causes changes to the
functioning of that brain in Hannah's
case it took several weeks for doctors
to recognize that this was a serious
autoimmune condition that required
treatment with very heavy duty drugs I
was moved to the neurology Ward I was
completely mute
um and I had lost the ability to dress
myself wash myself feed myself so I
really was trapped in my own body at
this stage Hannah underwent
immunotherapy treatment and had 13
plasma exchanges a process of filtering
blood before pumping it back into her
body
although the treatment didn't work
initially and her parents were told by
doctors she probably didn't have long to
live after two weeks Hannah woke up
Hannah
Sage out and
over subsequent weeks she learned to
speak again and walk again she says it
was like learning how to live again I
look back at the person before I got
Encephalitis I don't really know her
um I just can't connect with that person
Five Years on Hannah has mostly
recovered though she is still on
immunotherapy treatment and that makes
her more vulnerable to infections and
could impact her fertility
I wish GPS would know more about
Encephalitis because they're the first
point of contact for a lot of patients
um I wish my GP knew more about it so
she could direct me in the right
um pathway if I was to think about all
the people who had Encephalitis and died
in psychiatric hospitals or Care Homes I
wouldn't be able to sleep at night
in Hannah's case a physical illness
Encephalitis was mistaken for Mental
Illness but sometimes it's the other way
around we know that the connection
between body and mind goes both ways
physical problems can result in
psychiatric symptoms but also
psychological issues can contribute to
physical disease professor leschinner
says he sees patients who have symptoms
like seizures paralysis and numbness
with no obvious physical cause
some are eventually diagnosed as having
functional neurological disorder or fnd
which is a problem with how the brain
receives and sends information to the
rest of the body we don't fully
understand what causes these conditions
it seems that anybody can be vulnerable
to changes within the software that
defines how our nervous systems work we
know that there are some risk factors so
stress anxiety depression previous
psychological trauma in particular But
ultimately anybody can develop these
functional neurological disorders
globally hundreds of thousands of people
develop fnd every year conditions like
fnd and the experiences of people like
Hannah have led some doctors to believe
that we need to stop thinking of mental
and physical health as separate I think
we need to move away from defining
diseases or disorders as of the body and
of the mind we know that actually in
almost all cases there are
both even in conditions that are thought
to have a pure physical basis we know
that how people interpret their symptoms
is important in terms of defining their
quality of life and and how severe they
perceive their symptoms to be so
actually understanding that making sure
that everybody has access to both
physical and psychological treatments is
really of utmost importance for pretty
much every condition that is seen by our
Health Care Systems and is important for
everyone
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video